Les différences hommes femmes dans
le monde du travail? Ch’comprends pas les filles et les garçons c'est pareil
Les différences hommes et femmes dans
le monde du travail? Ch’ais pas c'est quoi
Les différences entre hommes et femmes dans
le monde du travail? ça sert à rien ça
le monde du travail? C'est quoi?
Les différences entre hommes et femmes dans
le monde du travail? Prrutt!
Les différences hommes femmes dans
le monde du travail? Ca m’a l’air pas mal ça
Les différences hommes et femmes dans
le monde du travail?c'est quoi ça?
le monde du travail? Ch’ais pas c'est quoi
Les différences hommes femmes dans
le monde du travail? Ca peut faire un bon spectacle ça
Les différences entre hommes et femmes dans
le milieu du travail? Et ben bonne chance pour les filles !
le milieu du travail? Ah, c’est IM-POR-TANT!
Hommes et femmes, filles et garçons… Quel
programme!
Alors, fondamentalement, en biologie, qu’est-ce
qui différencie un organisme masculin d’un
organisme féminin?
C’est en 1959 qu'on a enfin pu apporter
un élément de réponse à cette question.
Les chercheurs découvrent alors que sur les
46 chromosomes que contiennent chaque cellule,
deux d’entre eux sont spécifiquement liés
au sexe de l’individu. Ce sont les fameux
chromosomes X et Y.
L’idée est simple: les femmes présentent
deux chromosomes X, alors que les hommes présentent
un chromosome X et un chromosome Y. Et c’est
ce chromosome Y qui entraîne le déterminisme
sexuel par un mécanisme qu’on ne connaît
pas encore très bien.
Bien évidemment, les différences entre hommes
et femmes ne s’arrêtent pas au stade moléculaire.
Une fois différencié, l’appareil génital
va produire les hormones caractéristiques
à chaque sexe.
Ainsi, la femme a un taux plus élevé d’œstrogènes
alors que l’homme a un taux plus élevé
d’androgènes.
testostérone!
Ces hormones vont induire des différences
sexuelles anatomiques dès la naissance, mais
aussi, et surtout, à la puberté.
Les poils par exemple!
Et l’ossature aussi!
Et la poitrine aussi!
Ben quoi, vous voulez notre photo!
Et La voix aussi!
Testostérone!
Et les muscles!
En plus des différences physiques, il y a
aussi l’éducation, le milieu où l’on
vit, notre environnement, qui influencent
beaucoup nos comportements de fille ou de
garçon.
Le test de Rey est un bon exemple.
Il s’agit d’une figure géométrique complexe,
qu’il faut reproduire de mémoire après
un temps d’observation. dans ce domaine
Si les élèves font ce test en classe de
mathématiques, le taux de réussite des garçons
est plus élevé.
Si le test est réalisé en classe d’arts
plastiques, cette fois, le taux de réussite
des filles est plus élevé.
Alors, que nous montre ce test? Que les
idées reçues et l’environnement peuvent
nous conditionner!
Comme on a tendance à dire que les filles
sont plus douées en arts plastiques que les
garçons, alors, inconsciemment, les filles
réussissent mieux le test en Arts plastiques.
Et inversement, comme on a tendance à dire
que les garçons sont plus doués en maths,
ils réussissent mieux le test en classe de
maths.
En réalité, tout le monde a des aptitudes
différentes, et qui n’ont rien à voir
avec le sexe! Je peux être un garçon nul
en maths et très fort en arts plastiques
et une fille très forte en maths et absolument
nulle en dessin!
Alors moi par exemple, je suis fort en maths
ET en arts plastiques…
Moi je suis forte en maths et en art plastique!
Moi je suis fort en maths!
Aventurons nous maintenant dans le monde professionnel!
Jusque dans les années 60, la plupart des
femmes ne vont pas travailler: elle restent
à la maison et s’occupent du quotidien,
c’est à dire des enfants, des courses,
de la cuisine, du ménage, mais aussi des
travaux de la ferme quand elles habitent à
la campagne.
C’est le mari qui part travailler, et les
statistiques montrent qu’ à cette époque,
seulement 34% des femmes travaillaient en
dehors de chez elles.
Mais à partir des années 60, ça commence
à changer . Même si jusqu’en 1964 elles
sont obligées d’ avoir l’autorisation
de leurs maris pour travailler, de plus en
plus de femmes entrent dans ce qu’on appelle
la vie active.
Ta journée s'est bien passée?
En fait, j’ai bien réfléchi, et j'aimerais bien
travailler
Quoi? Travailler ?
J'ai bien réfléchi, et j'aimerais
travailler
Eh les gars, vous savez quoi,
elle veut travailler!
Non mais elle est dingue !
On auras tout vu ! De mieux en mieux !
Eh, on va boire un coup pour fêter ça?
Comme vous venez de le voir, ça n’était
pas toujours facile pour les femmes dans les
années 60, de rentrer dans ce monde du travail
qui appartenait aux hommes!
Ce n’était pas encore admis dans la société
de l’époque que les femmes travaillent
aussi, à l’égal des hommes.
Faisons maintenant un saut de 35 ans dans
le temps!
Voici le témoignage de Françoise, une femme
pompier que nous avons rencontrée, aujourd’hui
cheffe de sa caserne, et qui nous a raconté
le jour où elle s’est présentée pour
la 1ere fois dans une caserne, en 1995.
Bonjour, j'aimerais bien être pompier!
Ah, ça tombe bien, j'en ai une pour passer le balais, je vais en avoir une deuxième pour passer la serpillère, bienvenue
Et oui, encore en 1995, les mentalités n’avaient
pas complètement évolué!
Les hommes ne considéraient toujours pas
les femmes comme leurs égales…
Ensuite, Françoise nous a expliqué que beaucoup
de choses ont changé depuis. Par exemple,
les vestiaires pour se changer sont séparées
maintenant, les femmes ont les leurs.
Le matériel aussi s’est automatisé, allégé,
pour que les femmes ou les hommes puissent
l’utiliser de la même façon.
Et puis Françoise nous disait aussi que dans
certaines situations d’intervention des
pompiers, le fait d’être une femme était
un avantage: avec des enfants, par exemple,
ou des femmes enceintes, ou encore quand il
faut rentrer dans une voiture accidentée,
et que l’entrée est vraiment petite, à
ce moment là, une femme peut plus facilement
se faufiler qu'un homme.
Nous avons aussi rencontré Marie, qui travaille
dans une entreprise de démolition, et où
il y a peu de femmes. Elle adore son métier,
elle s’occupe de la sécurité sur les chantiers,
mais elle nous a aussi parlé de certaines
difficultés parfois à se faire traiter en
égale vis à vis des hommes.
Les garçons on vas commencer la réunion ?
Les garçons, on commence la réunion ou quoi ?
Ooh, les garçons je suis là, on commence la réunion?
Les garçons ! La réunion, tout de suite !
Mais les garçons on a une réunion très importante, c'est tout de suite !
Woh je suis là ! écoutez moi !
(Coup de siflet)
Qu'est-ce qu'elle a poulette ?
Je ne suis pas une poulette! On a une réunion très importante...
Tu avais pas un truc à me dire?
eh oh écoutez moi !
Comme vous venez de le voir, il est difficile
encore aujourd’hui pour les femmes d’être
traitées d’égale à égal dans leur travail,
surtout quand elles exercent une profession
où il y a beaucoup d’hommes!
se faire appeler par des petits noms
ou se faire siffler, sont des choses qui arrivent encore aujourd'hui mais qui sont plus rare
En revanche qu'une femme se fasse couper la parole en réunion, ça c'est très fréquent
Globalement, on constate qu’au travail,
une femme doit montrer qu'elle connaît
davantage de choses, être sûre d'elle, faire
ses preuves et en même temps garder une certaine
discrétion.
Et puis, nous n’avons pas parlé des salaires,
et pourtant, dans certaines entreprises, l’égalité
homme-femme n’est pas toujours respectée dans ce domaine!
Jason, Carla, je suis très fier de vous, vous avez bien travaillés, du coup
vous allez avoir une prime
Eh oui, les différences de salaires! Dans
certaines entreprises, pour le même poste,
le même travail, les mêmes compétences,
un employé homme sera payé au moins 25%
de plus qu’une employée femme!
Alors que proposer pour que ces différences
homme-femme n’existent plus demain dans
le monde du travail?
Il faut lutter quotidiennement contre les
idées reçues et les préjugés! Faire
attention à la télévision, à la publicité,
ou aux magazines, qui imposent très souvent
des stéréotypes de genres et nous conditionnent
dès tout petits!
Et il faut faire appliquer la loi dans toutes
les entreprises, puisqu’elle existe : notamment
celle du 4 août 2014, pour l’égalité
réelle entre les femmes et les hommes!
Et n’oublions pas que le monde de demain
c’est nous, alors à nous de jouer!